let's go next to our caller from the
3:08 area code who is calling today from
3:08
hey can you hear me yes I can't who's
this this is Kowalski from Nebraska hey
Kowalski what's up
well I just wanted to call in and say
well actually I was just kind of curious
last year the Midwest received like
record flooding and I was just curious
how much that like hit the radar of
people who live and you know the more
popular areas of the country that's a
good question I think where you made a
world no call story at it was I mean I
remember hearing about flooding here in
from here in Boston but it it was
certainly not like a major story but you
know part of that maybe I don't really
watch sort of like regular news where
you just get you know a breakdown of
what's going on in the news I'm pretty
narrowly consuming political news so it
also may have been that just in my
circles it wasn't being talked about as
much but I I didn't hear that much about
it I admit hmm
we do have like a dam failure and stuff
and unfortunately it's looking like
we're not going to have that great of a
spring so we might be looking at some
flooding again but I was just a
generally curious how well that hit your
radar and also I recently talked to some
people from the Austin era clicking on
some agricultural software and stuff and
they're pretty swell people gotta admit
you guys have some pretty nice folks in
the neighborhood yeah I mean they do is
there the belief in Nebraska that people
in Boston are not nice well I'm more
from the rural area of Nebraska so I'm
not like Omaha or anything I'm central
Nebraska and there's kind of that
feeling of what the coasts or ignorant
so to speak but I gotta say these people
had really you know just open minds and
we're very compassionate and I generally
like them so that's fascinating so there
are the stereotype Merle several
Nebraska well hold on a second you're
shot out of a cannon today the in in in
central rural Nebraska there's a
stereotype
that the people on the coasts are the
ignorant ones ignorant of
agriculturalists okay like yeah like
there's this idea that goes around that
and actually to be fair they admitted to
this too that many generations removed
from agriculture don't really understand
like the processes and stuff and I had
to admit before going to like the
university it was kind of an eye-opener
to me how limited people's knowledge of
like agriculture is but you know you are
your environment so it just makes sense
yeah I grew up in western Massachusetts
where there are a lot of farms but
they're they're relatively small it's
not the large-scale farming that you see
you know in other parts of the country
including the Midwest and in that
gravitational pull of you know it being
just deep dominant industry and
everything so it just does overwhelm
your whole life but I'm not really an
active listener of your show i watch a
lot of it and passing like you know some
of the stuff you put out I think you do
some good work and whatnot so yeah let's
just keep up the support there to the
folks in Iowa make sure you give those
folks a call and I hope you have a good
day hey and listen how rural is your
living situation like how long of a ride
is it just to go to the grocery store
for me it's not too bad I live outside
of a it's actually the largest city in
Nebraska's third District so I only live
like a few miles away but I've got a lot
of friends and we do a lot of business
and like some of the more rural areas
and I got to say okay just so you know I
am a registered Republican although I
would consider myself more of a Radical
Republican so to speak I generally am
like just somebody who thinks that if
you're gonna live here go with the
dominant party and do your best to make
it moderate that makes sense
I understand what you're under stand
what you're saying yeah but so you were
talking about how rural it is yeah so
like where I'm at isn't actually too bad
because I am close to a larger community
of like 55,000 but a lot of the area's I
go to and where a lot of my friends are
from they do not have those luxuries are
like
have to travel a couple hours to go to
the stores Wow got basically food
deserts yeah and the big problem we are
facing is medical care
yeah like problem is you can't really
have a heart attack in the middle of
nowhere because even a helicopter will
still take you know two hours to get you
where you need to be yep so that is one
thing like I have been telling a lot of
people around here that you know Sanders
plan for Medicare for all does include
like just straight-up subsidies for
rural communities to have clinics to
have full-time nurses and whatnot and
that would go a long way of also
bringing outside resources to help
revitalize rural America so I keep
telling everybody you got to take a pipe
issue-by-issue basis you know so like
when it comes to health care
Sanders clearly closes everyone a hook
water sure but uh you know it just
depends on your priorities but I would
say decline all right Kowalski so I'm
gonna let you go but I appreciate
hearing from you and super super
interesting to hear from someone in
relatively rural Nebraska let's take a
quick break if you're holding don't hang
up because I will go right back to the
phones after this short break